new developments on the southern border
tonight it's becoming obvious that open
borders are in effect the policy the
official policy of the biden
administration axios reports tonight
that approximately 50
000 migrants cross caught crossing the
southern border
have been released into our country
without a court date
now technically those migrants have been
instructed to report to ice offices but
they don't studies show only about 10
percent of them
have done probably fewer than that will
an immigration official just told this
show that this is now
standard operating procedure so you get
caught crossing the border not just from
mexico or honduras or guatemala but
maybe from across the ocean
maybe from the middle east from africa
from the caribbean and you're told to
show up at an ice office wherever you
choose to settle
and according to two whistleblowers from
joe biden's hhs
many of these migrants are infected with
covet 19.
quote hundreds of children contracted
covet in the overcrowded conditions in
the migrant shelters
the whistleblower said in a new federal
complaint adequate mass were not
consistently provided to children nor
was their use consistently
enforced think about that your
kindergartner is going to be forced to
wear a mask because the teachers unions
are in charge of the bite
administration's health policy
but illegal migrants with covet don't
have to wear masks how does that work
well because they're future democratic
party voters
they can do what they want and we know
that by administration is not even
bothering to figure out where they're
going
this is one of the great scandals of our
age
and no one is stopping it we went down
to the border town of uvalde texas for a
brand new episode of our documentary
series it's called tucker carlson
originals the documentary is called the
illegal invasion
and it's a look at why so many illegal
aliens are flooding the border and what
they've done to the people who live
there
here's a look at what we found
joe biden took office in january of 2021
one of the very first things he did was
deliberately provoke what may be the
largest surge in illegal immigration in
american history
nobody is going to be deported in my
first hundred days
foreign nationals from around the world
from congo to haiti to honduras and
guatemala and el salvador to the middle
east
all heard joe biden's call
ghana you're from ghana in the first six
months of the biden presidency nearly a
million
foreign nationals arrived in this
country they came up through mexico
what is life like for the americans who
live along the mexican border
we thought we'd find out in the last six
months it's become the wild wild west
don mclaughlin is the mayor of uvalde
texas
jivaldi is about 60 miles from the
mexican border
we interviewed him earlier this year
when we did he invited us to come visit
him in uvalde
we took him up on the offer this is what
we found the mass arrival of foreign
nationals into this small texas town
has made life miserable for the people
who live there
this has become a third world country
weston robertson lives on 22 acres near
the railroad tracks i
carry a fair arm 24 hours a day out here
all the time even my mother who is
elderly
will not even leave the house go outside
the water flowers without her personally
carrying a firearm if you live on the
edge of town and you're out in your yard
chances are you've got a shotgun or a
pistol out there with you and it
shouldn't be that way
but it is that way uvalde residents
watch helplessly as central americans
haitians even people from africa cross
their fields break into their sheds
and camp on their land they're coming
into these cars and spending the night
there's food package from where they're
sitting in here eating
since the new administration took office
the federal government is no longer
willing to enforce existing immigration
law
americans living in uvalde have no
option but to defend themselves
i cannot even go from my house to my
barn or
to their chicken coop or anywhere
without carrying a gun
i don't even leave my house without it
this woman spoke on the condition of
anonymity
she fears retaliation from the mexican
cartels which she says are
operating in uvalde i came out one day
had four men running directly at my
house
where one tried to break into our house
while i was here
our crime's up our car break-ins are up
our house burglaries are up
it seems like we just don't have as many
rights as even the legals do
you know i will defend my house if i had
to
you can watch a full episode of that
it's called the illegal invasion it hits
foxnation.com tomorrow morning
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else